is she using the leaf to blot her tears
it would be weird to give her tissue
Mira we make children's books maybe it's
better to prepare them life will
inevitably Crush their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting his whole
number
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
I miss you so much there's an aching
inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Mr do
you really believe in all these things
you sing you obviously know nothing
about it what
[Music]
it's been two years since you passed and
I still can't believe it who is sending
me these texts every morning I open my
eyes hoping I'll still see you I must
have the dead boyfriend's number that's
super sad I think they're nice there is
nothing wrong with putting yourself back
out there again you're going there get
the D you make it sound like I have a
vitamin deficiency yeah you kind of do
you have a vitamin D deficiency because
when the sun comes up maybe we just take
it a little slower go
they're never gonna hold me down I think
I might have feelings for someone I've
never met these sticks you're receiving
are saying something it might be crazy
but love doesn't always follow the rules
[Music]
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight I'm
gonna go see her these are from a
literal stranger I just need to put a
face to these texts
[Music]
I know you I'm not sure oh my God you
just got yourself a date the normal way
she thinks I am interesting you need to
tell her the truth you should have said
something to her right away
I tell her she'll never speak to me
again
I was looking forward to this I just
felt wherever I knew you or something do
you think you could fall in love with
someone just through their words
I think you're very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
[Music]
it's like this don't
happen love is a plan for each and every
one of us
hi this is Celine Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]
foreign